Muy buenas tardes Pues los ánimos
digamos la gran tristeza porque los
iraníes lucharon hasta el último minuto
de este partido para poder empatar para
poder clasificar a la siguiente ronda
los hinchas pues terminaron tomandose
fotos Todo estaba muy en calma pero sí
se vivieron momentos de tensión
justamente después cuando ya estaban
saliendo del estadio esto quedó
registrado de hecho por algunos de
nuestros colegas tanto de Francia 24 en
inglés como en francés algunos de esas
personas tenían camisetas algunos de
estos hinchas iraníes tenían camisetas a
favor de las mujeres en Irán y
finalmente fueron guardos de seguridad
de el estadio que al parecer los
agredieron algunos de ellos incluso
estaban ensangrentados y de hecho varios
de estos de guardas trataron incluso o
agredieron de hecho a nuestros
compañeros Así que unos momentos de
detención en un estadio en el que de
hecho los guardas de seguridad a lo
largo de este partido Pues iban y
bajaban y están muy pendientes de todo
lo que ocurría en estas gradas a pesar
de que todo era un muy buen ambiente
también Natalia hablemos ahora de los
partidos de importancia para nuestro
continente el día de hoy que necesitan
Argentina y México para pasar a la
siguiente fase
Raúl necesitan ganar Esa es la palabra
del día de hoy para poder depender de sí
mismas porque Argentina pues va a
enfrentarse a Polonia muchos ven este
partido como uno Duelo entre lewandowski
y entre Messi Leonel escalón y el
director director técnico de Argentina
dijo ayer que lo que más le preocupaba
era la altura de los jugadores de
Polonia son muy altos mientras que la
selecciona Argentina pues es una de las
más bajitas la segunda más bajita de
todo este mundial en todo caso pues
Argentina necesita eso para no tener que
depender con lo que suceda en el partido
entre México y Arabia Saudita México
necesita entonces también ganar sobre
todo porque de ganar areves ahorita bien
Podría ponerse como primero de este
grupo